all right so i was watching a a thing
the other day uh about how this black
family was trying to sell their home and
they were trying to sell it and they got
it appraised and it was appraised for
400 000
and they were like this doesn't feel
right because we did a lot of work on
the house and then they went to go uh
get it appraised but with a white family
so they took all their pictures out of
their black family all of they had some
black artwork or whatever the [ __ ] and
and um
they moved they
they no remnants of of anything black in
there no no no no pictures no nothing
and then they had a white family get the
[ __ ] of praise and they got appraised
for 300 000 more dude and that's crazy
now whatever you want to blame the
system the people the person who was
[ __ ] doing the appraisal whatever you
want to blame it has to do with racism
in some way all right okay
like even if you're like well they don't
want to live there that's not their
fault if they don't want it's racist to
not want to live near blacks it's racist
to not want to live near [ __ ]
whatever near whites it's whatever it is
there's racism somehow whether it's in
the system or with each person or
whatever and i understand we're not
going to solve that tomorrow or whatever
the [ __ ] but um
that's crazy to me
like racism okay at some point i get it
like if you're gonna be 75 years old and
you're white and you just want to chill
with a bunch of other white people till
you die that's the amount of racist that
i think it's okay
right you're not outwardly doing
anything shitty towards any other race
if you're [ __ ] 85 years old and
you're black and you kind of just want
to chill with some black people till the
day you die and you don't really want to
be bothered by white people i get it
that's the level of racism that i think
is okay
and we can also still function nicely as
a society
and i don't think that we can really get
beyond that i think that as humans we're
tribal and there's we have that in us
right okay okay
but
three hundred thousand dollars racist is
insane dude
but this stuff happens look it happened
this stuff happens is it okay it's not
okay it's hard it sucks
and it leads to all sorts of other [ __ ]
that [ __ ] up the world and it's bad now
i know because i'm a smart person that
that's bad okay but this
this was great
there was a guy a black guy watering i
mean not great but there was a black guy
watering his neighbor's plants because
of
the
the the neighbors left town and they
wanted this dude to look after the
plants and he came over and was watering
the plants for the people
and someone a warm late spring evening
in the small alabama town of
childersburg
police are responding to a 9-1-1 call
from i mean this guy's a voice dude have
you ever heard i was by the way this
voice that people
a black pastor arrested while watering
neighbors flowers he was supposed to be
doing it but someone called of
suspicious behavior and dude like that's
always the voice you know it's either
that or like this is how it is in sports
events dude have you ever seen a
sporting event where the guys don't talk
like that i have college college
football
i watch college football i watch the
seminals versus the [ __ ] uh
i don't know who cares who cares really
but i watched them and this and they
were just dudes that were like oh man
whoa whoa oh wow threw it over there
whoa that's crazy oh look at that oh
yeah it's a touchdown hey all right he
got a touchdown it was not of this stuff
and it was so [ __ ] weird dude you got
to have the voice this is the voice
we're all accustomed to have the voice
my neighbor reporting she sees a young
black male in the car
she doesn't recognize at her neighbor's
home who she knows are away
we're watching the police body cam
footage
what officers find is a man holding a
garden hose
watering flowers
what are you doing
his whole life
[Laughter]
just
absolutely knows what's about to go down
you know what i'm talking about dude
imagine black people doing this [ __ ] and
doing nothing at all and then the cops
show up and they're just like here the
[ __ ] we goddamn go again dude this guy
couldn't be doing something more
peaceful even if he is
at a stranger's house he's still helping
he's watering the plants it's hot out
even if it is a suspicious person dude
if i if i walk out if i'm if i peek
outside someone's watering my plants i
don't give a [ __ ] who they are i don't
say nothing i let them finish up and
leave then i don't have to do it
are they saying that is that your
vehicle
it's not
you live here no i don't even
okay uh they saying that this vehicle is
not supposed to be here and you're not
supposed to be here
they called about it i don't know who
caught i'm supposed to be here i'm
pastor jennings i live across the street
dude he's a pastor of all couldn't be
more innocent dude
couldn't be
more innocent
just
nah nah uh uh that's cute man i'm
supposed to be here just starts spraying
like just knows what's up oh you're
gonna be racist okay i'm pastor
[ __ ] the
subdued
gotcha in his voice oh no i'm supposed
to be here i'm pastor without looking
and spraying is so the [ __ ] dude what's
saying i'm not supposed to be here no
i'm supposed to be here i'm a pastor
you're pastor jenny yes i'm looking out
for the house while they go the scene
quickly escalates when police demand 56
year old michael jennings a pastor of 31
years provide some identification
look man don't do this to me
there's a suspicious person in the yard
[Music]
[Applause]
and where he lives
refuses he don't live
i'm not saying nothing about it you have
no right to approach me if i ain't did
nothing suspicious or nothing wrong
moments later when jennings attempts to
use his cell phone he's placed in
handcuffs
who called
you know i get
i get like comply i get it i get that
like cops can do whatever they really
can do whatever they want it's like you
have no right it's used for you to say
to a cop you have no right to do this
they get you on something you know like
they
i get it but for having to deal with
this [ __ ] their whole lives i under i
also understand that look [ __ ]
i'm not doing anything people are out
there robbing and stealing and [ __ ] let
me just water these goddamn plants
because i'm black you [ __ ] i was
called obviously what's uh like why what
where's what i don't get about and i
support the i'm not one of these
[ __ ] that's like [ __ ] defund
the police i think that's utterly
[ __ ] idiotic we need police the crime
in l.a sucks because they don't have
enough the police don't have enough
money because [ __ ] we're we're cucks
you know what i'm saying is too liberal
all right so by no means am i saying oh
defund the police [ __ ] the police [ __ ]
all cop nah i the we need them okay i
want all the cops i want more cops all
right
but
i don't understand why when a cop shows
up
to this house
and sees what's actually happened they
don't say oh
i get what's happening
it's
racism ah
racism again
the only
thing that i can understand is is that
the cops are racist and maybe they are
maybe they are but they're not racist
cause they're cops
people have all sorts of different
levels of racism you know and i think
that it's kind of like i said we're
tribal and if you want to be 80 and
asian and only hang out with asian
people that's the amount in racism
that's totally down but three hundred
thousand dollars racism this is how much
it is this is beyond this is three
hundred thousand dollars racist that's
what that is
i don't know why cops don't show up and
they say oh he's watering oh yeah the
[ __ ] chick she was probably white
let's go [ __ ] talk to her
because then they're like well why don't
you show us the identification we have
to arrest you if you don't and then the
black guy is like well i shouldn't have
to do that just because i'm black and
you get the thing and i get it
let it go dude
let it go
let it go
that's what the [ __ ] disney song's
about racism secretly
homie no we let it go
let it go
let it go
[Music]
crazy
crazy
[Music]